welcome back we've been talking about
data-driven control and in particular
how we can use machine learning and
related optimization techniques to
either discover a model of a system or
to directly discover effective control
laws using using data and optimization
what I'm going to tell you about right
now is an adaptive control strategy
called extremum seeking control so
extremum seeking extreme seeking control
is an equation free control law so this
is equation free or adaptive meaning
that it doesn't require you to have a
model of the system and it can adapt to
slowly changing parameters right so if I
have a system that ages or it changes
over the course of a day then this
extreme seeking control is going to be
able to compensate for those parameter
changes with even without modeling or
measuring them and extreme can seeking
control is an extremely useful powerful
and effective method of optimization for
control that I use quite frequently so
if there's ever a problem where I don't
want to model the system and I have a
control knob and there's some kind of
overarching objective function or cost
function that I want to maximize or
minimize then I usually will try extreme
seeking control at least in my first
round of things that I try ok so extreme
seeking control was largely developed by
Miroslav Krista at UCSD and so I suggest
that you go read some of those
foundational papers and I'll give you
some links links to those papers and
books ok so I'm going to walk you
through just the simplest simplest
example of an extreme seeking controller
making a bunch of kind of assumptions
that make it easy to explain but then
we'll break down those assumptions later
so in general we're going to assume that
we have some kind of system the system
is going to have inputs u and outputs Y
and those outputs are going to feed into
cost function or objective function
maybe let me call this an objective
function because I'm gonna want to
maximize the objective not minimize a
cost okay
so some objective function J and I can
I'm basically assuming that if I move
you I can get a measurement of J okay I
can measure the the measurements that
feed into my objective function and then
extremely seeking control is going to
feed back that measurement and do
something to try to optimize optimize
you to maximize maximize J okay so the
general theory of extreme seeking
control applies to dynamical systems
systems with changing parameters lots
and lots of cases what I'm going to do
is I'm going to consider a massively
oversimplified case to start with where
my cost function or my objective
function J let's call this my objective
J as a function of U is just a static
function it's a static paraboloid okay
and so that means essentially that the
system dynamics respond instantaneously
to a new actuation signal you give me
some measurements Y and some
corresponding cost function J so I'm
assuming the simplest case where there's
a single global maximum to my objective
function and then my dynamics respond
instantaneously to actuation you now
that doesn't have to be the case but
this is just to illustrate how extremely
seeking control works okay so in this
diagram here what we notice first of all
is that there is an optimal control
value U star which corresponds to the
peak in my objective function so what I
want to do is I want to steer whatever
my U is I want to find U star and track
that U star so even if this J slowly
varies over the day and this peak moves
I want to track that optimal u that
gives me the maximum and my objective
function
that's what extremists seeking does so
let's do a thought experiment the the
basic thought experiment here is
that I'm going to have some estimate for
what my best controller is and let's
call that you hat so I have some
estimate for my control law u hat and
I'm just gonna draw u hat here so let's
say I have I think that it's u equals
two okay what I'm going to do or what
extreme seeking control does is it adds
to that best estimate it adds a sine
wave perturbation okay so it adds some a
sine omega-t
to that and that's what my actual U is
so I take my my estimate for the best
control the optimizing control Lu hat
let's draw a dashed line this is U hat
and what I do is I add on to that a
sinusoidal perturbation and what I what
the sinusoidal perturbation does is it
essentially probes what the slope of
this cot this objective function is at
that particular value of U hat so let's
walk through this this thought
experiment okay so so I'm at this U hat
and if I held that u hat constant my J
would be constant just have this value
of J but if I swing my control if I
swing my let's say my u hat when I swing
it positive or negative when I swing u
hat in the positive direction
my objective goes up okay so I get a
bump in my objective function so my
objective function goes up when my u hat
goes to the right and when my u hat goes
to the left when it's more negative my
objective function goes down so I
measure this decrease in my objective
function J given that u hat now this J
has some some average value that's not
zero because it's way up here but if I
if I if I made it so that it was zero
mean if I subtract it out the mean and
then multiplied these two what I would
end up getting is a signal that is
merely purely positive okay because if I
multiply two sine waves that are
relatively in phase I'll get something
that is
mostly positive plus times plus as plus
minus times minus is plus okay and so
what this tells me is that if I am to
the left of my optimum so that the slope
of the cost function is positive giving
this little perturbation signal and
measuring the output perturbation if I
multiply those two I would get a signal
that's mostly positive and that mostly
positive signal tells me hey I should be
moving that way I should be moving to
the right okay let's see how this works
this works over here let's say now I'm
to the right of my objective dot
similarly I'm going to add a sine wave
I'm going to go up here and now I'm
going to do the exact same thing I have
my J function and I have let's draw my
you down here my you signal so now if my
you swings to the right so if my you
swings to the right here I measure a
decrease in power okay so now these are
out of phase and if I swing to the left
I measure an increase in objective
function I sometimes I say power because
I use this to optimize power in systems
and so now I get a J and a u that are
out of phase okay and if I multiplied
these let's do this in orange if I
multiply these guys then I would get a
signal that is mostly negative plus
times minus is minus plus times minus is
minus and so what that orange signal
tells me is hey I'm in a place that has
a negative slope I better go to the left
okay so the basic idea here is that I
inject some perturbation sinusoid on to
my best estimate of my control U hat I
measure what the sinusoidal perturbation
on the output J is and it can either be
in phase when I'm to the left of the
optimum or out of phase when I'm to the
right of the optimum and if I added this
multiplied signal to my you had if I
integrated that multiplied signal I
would tend to move in the right
direction so let's work that out in this
control diagram here okay so remember
this
did not have a zero mean so I had to
subtract out the mean that's pretty easy
to do by just applying a high-pass
filter
okay so high-pass filter and in
frequency domain in the Laplace
transform domain that would look
something like s over s plus some high
frequency Omega H okay and then remember
what I'm doing is I'm taking that
high-pass filter so only the high
frequency stuff not the DCE or
steady-state component I'm high-pass
filtering that let's call that high pass
filtered signal row I'm taking Rho times
my perturbation signal a sine Omega T
okay and I'm multiplying the two
together so I want to multiply this with
my sinusoidal perturbation a sine Omega
T and sometimes in some extreme of
seeking controllers you phase shift this
a little bit to get it to line up better
okay and so this is kind of a tuning
parameter that you can play with usually
I start with this equal to zero and I
just use my input sine and I directly
multiply it by this high pass filtered
output okay and this essentially gives
me the orange signal so at this point I
multiplied my sinusoid by my high pass
filtered output and I have this kind of
orange this is called a demodulated
signal demodulated and it's generally
mostly positive when i'm to the left and
mostly negative when I'm to the right of
the optimum and so what I actually want
to do is I want to add I want to
integrate this I want to add that to u
hat so basically I'm just going to
continually integrate let's write
integrate this into my best estimate and
an integrator in the frequency domain is
just 1 over s the Laplace variable s
maybe I multiply this by some gain K
okay so this is actually completely the
extreme seeking control diagram this is
basic
we all there is for this simple example
you might ask what happens when I
actually get to the top of this this
objective function when I actually move
this system to the right and actually
get to U star let's look at what that
that output signal looks like okay so if
I had now a sinusoidal input about the
optimal frequency then the output
function J so J or kind of this
demodulated row let's say I swing to the
right of you well if I swing to swing to
the right
I go down but only a teeny tiny amount
okay so I swing down a little bit and if
I swing so that was if I had a positive
swing in you now if I have a negative
swing in you I also go down and this is
kind of interesting so you basically
either direction if I jiggle you I go
down because I'm at the peak of J and if
I multiply this with my my signal you
basically I get something which is
averages out to be neither positive nor
negative so I get something that's a
little bit positive here and a little
bit negative there and basically this
signal when I add it to this best
estimate it doesn't move okay all right
so I want to walk you through this one
more time now that we have the diagram
and we have all of these sine waves okay
what is extra so you can control two
extremes you can control is an
optimization technique that jiggles your
input signal you it jiggles that input
signal and if it measures when it when
it swings when you swings positive if J
goes up and if you swing positive J's
goes down then it adds a little positive
number it integrates that little
positive number into my best estimate
you hat and I step to the right okay now
if I was to the right of my optimum and
I did the same thing I jiggle my you
sinusoidal e now if I swing you positive
and I measure our drop in J and if I
swing you negative and I measure a bump
in J that tells me this demodulated
signal tells me that I need to move left
okay and this demodulated signal
sometimes we call this
this is sigh sigh sigh okay so the basic
idea is extremely seeking control just
jiggles the input you and that probes
the slope of this objective function if
it's a positive slope you take a step in
the positive direction if it's a
negative slope you take a step in the
negative direction the nice thing about
this also is that if I'm in a region
that has a higher slope this is a bigger
sinusoidal swing and this C signal will
be bigger so I will take larger steps
when I'm in a region of really really
big slope and then when I get to regions
of really really minor slope this sign
is so I get smaller and my steps get
smaller so the farther away I am with a
higher slope for my objective the bigger
step I'll take the faster all approach
and then as I get to the top kind of
everything slows down and I just hang
out around there okay so this does rely
on you having access to your control
signal and being able to put in this a
little sinusoidal jiggle to probe the
system this is really really closely
related to another older method called
perturb and observe which is basically
the simplest thing you would think of to
optimize to find this U star and what
perturb and observe does is it basically
takes a little discrete steps it says
okay I'm going to take it discreet step
in you did my power did my J go up or
down if it went up take another step if
it went down take a step in the opposite
direction extreme seeking control is
essentially a continuous time version of
perturb and observe but instead of just
taking fixed discrete Delta U steps it
can take bigger or smaller steps
depending on on the slope or the
gradient of this cost function J so it's
it's kind of a generalization which is
faster tracking because it takes bigger
steps when you have higher slope and
there's also provable guarantees on when
this will and will not converge for
dynamical systems so very very useful
this is just kind of the simplest
illustration of what's happening here
for a static objective function with
instantaneous dynamics
okay now there's a few assumptions I
made here and these assumptions are true
even when you're applying this to
dynamical systems so extremists seeking
control if all you were doing was just
finding some optimum point in a static
objective function this wouldn't be that
impressive there's lots and lots of
methods to do that but let's say over
time this system is actually depends on
some parameters so let's say that this
is some curve that changes over the
course of a day okay so over 24 hours
this this curve might move to the left
and move to the right slowly and so that
you star my maximum my maximizing input
U is also going to be moving to the left
and to the right so as long as those
disturbances or those parameter
variations are slow compared to this the
sinusoidal jiggle this extreme so you
can control all will be able to track
that optimizing controller over time and
keep your system performing at peak
performance that's really useful okay so
you assume that the disturbances to your
system the slow parameter variations are
the slowest timescale the next faster
timescale are these sinusoidal
perturbations that you're adding to the
system so these are faster than the
parameters and the disturbances of your
system and then the absolute fastest
timescale you assume that the system
dynamics respond faster than the
sinusoidal input perturbation
so you basically assume that as I'm
jiggling the system left and right the
dynamics of the system are very rapidly
kind of equilibrating and you can
measure some objective function for each
point in this sine wave okay
that's basically the assumption of
extremists you can control now I will
point out this is fundamentally a local
optimizer okay so if my objective
function instead of having just one peak
if it had let's say two peaks like this
if I started to the right I'm only gonna
converge to this first peak because it
won't allow me to go down to go to a
more global optimum okay so I think it's
very important also to recognize that
this
is a local local optimizer and so if I
have a very complex cost landscape with
you know global maximum and local Maxima
I have to be careful where I initialize
this extreme so you can control where I
start my best estimate you hat so that I
can climb that hill and get to that peak
performance okay so this does generalize
to dynamical systems we're going to try
this out on some examples I'm going to
show you lots of real world applications
where this works and we're also going to
code this up in MATLAB for this simple
example and see how everything works
okay thank you